guys today is new york city uh dion what
kind of map is this
um new york is a hybrid map so a brand
new hybrid map for overwatch too
and there's a fun new payload for
players to battle over
the world building team had a great time
just
creating this overwatch depiction of new
york tons of
neat details and fun easter eggs for the
players to find so
i i think it should be fun to take a
look at this
yeah no i when you guys showed this at a
blizzcon line i was so excited
obviously from new york uh myself would
love to see the midtown tunnel go over
some of the adjustments that you guys
have made to it here
in in overwatch too uh just
yeah just a beautiful map i have to
imagine this is one of the locales that
you guys have been dying to do for a
while
we've been wanting to there's a lot of
people on the team from new york or who
have spent some part of their life there
so
it's always been on the list and
overwatch 2 felt like the right time to
do it
and uh no short of easter eggs i would
say
no i know on some of these maps so far
uh please
you know get get some love at the
beginning but uh yeah this will be our
first real look
at 5v5 uh i've had the
opportunity to like kind of watch some
games like as they've kind of tested it
out
uh it it's it still keeps that overwatch
you know
fast-paced feel but it uh it doesn't
have like the you know kind of the the
clumped up chaos that you sometimes see
of live i think it kind of speaks to
really what you were pointing to
jeff is that when you have we know that
one less
tank in the equation you can actually
make the tanks more aggressive and more
offensive
uh but it's also just kind of easier for
the viewer and
just people at home to track yeah
absolutely
and um you'll see probably a lot of play
here
one of the biggest things you'll notice
because there's less protection
from coming from tank players just to
directly block bullets for the team
typically you will find a lot more
player on the map corners
map angles often try going for cheeky
flanks and stuff
dion loves this they get to use the
environment a lot more it's a bit more
tactical
yeah exactly which is great um
so it kind of you know that was one of
the first things that came out of our
original play testing and we were just
like this is
a really good direction i mean like i
mentioned there's like
you know as a designer you sort of have
to look past the immediate like problems
in front of you and like okay we could
fix those
like i think we can address uh you know
some of the like tank imbalances and
healing issues and all kinds of
stuff but at the heart of this was
really cool and so that's that's really
what we've been focusing on and working
through these problems
i think something that's really
interesting about that too is that
the gameplay is is more fluid than it
was before
a lot of times in overwatch you get
these these really hard battle lines
that
that get drawn between the two teams um
and there's just
less damage incoming um and so you're
able to kind of move around
a little bit more and um you'll see it
here a lot of times
um the chokes aren't as hard of a space
to
to get through there's still a choke in
the map and you still have to work at it
but there can be a lot more like pushing
through and and pulling back
on the choke and it's something that i'm
like personally personally really
excited about
i was going to say uh how has uh the 5v5
move affected
map design i feel like it kind of has to
have a huge impact on
what you guys are able to do create
different speaking about like players
being able to take more control of the
game right you know
creating more flanking routes you know
more opportunity for you know the the
ash to go to the side get a pick and
open things up for a team
yeah there's a lot more opportunity um
for for players to do that
um but at the same time um when when you
go for a flank
you're not leaving five players behind
you're leaving four players behind and
so
you you kind of have to be weighing some
of these decisions in your head the game
is just as strategic
as it was before um if not more so
because of the
the individual ability for players to
have such a large impact
on the match i think for map design
we've always been um really careful to
make spaces that feel good
just for one hero and sometimes
we might favor particular heroes in
different areas
but because of that because we're able
to to make a space that kind of feels
good for reaper or a space that feels
good for pharah
i think that we'll still be able to play
5v5
on all of the original catalog of
overwatch maps as well
right that is a awesome payload dion by
the way
and you know we've always in in the
artwork of the maps we've always placed
what we consider cover objects
it just feels now with the 5v5 players
will take advantage of that more you
know
even the previous maps we've we planned
cover objects to help protect players
now with 5v5 they're even more effective
these these artistic choices
it's such a great point too because we
have started placing a little bit more
cover in our maps
and if you go back to some of the old
maps like if you look at king's row
that middle section that street section
of king's row
there's one piece of cover in that
entire
section it's just corners of buildings
is what you're using
yeah no that's a that's a great point i
think you can kind of see it here even
with i know stuff like that i know the
taxis here in the streets you know you
have the little kind of windows
the pillar to hide behind in the middle
uh there's a route through the subway
there's so many different kind of angles
uh you can take uh something we saw uh
at blizzcon line was the
uh two fire strike charge uh cancel
reinhardt
uh i noticed something before jeff when
we were on with winston
uh my winston uh not able to shoot at
range can you can you explain that to us
a little bit so
i was wondering if people picked up on
that so we were first watching winston
there
um this is an example of you know some
of the tank changes we're talking about
um in regards to five to five but also a
larger change we're talking about making
tanks
uh a lot more aggressive be able to
be a little more hybridy on the damaged
side and less just raw protection
um so on winston's side um he's ultimate
unfortunately you can't see it but
he can't do it but his uh his alternate
fire there which is doing right now
there it is
you can charge up like a condensed blast
of lightning from his gun and fire it
off as a single
sort of like a blast attack at longer
range
um and so he actually the charge up is
kind of interesting with it for him
because you could do it while you're
leaping
and so there's like theoretically more
burst combos you can do where you're
jumping on top of somebody charging up
in the air and first you know
release it right before you land on them
and then you get the stomp damage too
and
you can shock them or do a quick melee
combo there's a lot more interesting
things on top of the fact that
you know there's some players know a lot
of times you're you're you know you
shock somebody they're getting away
you think you can finish them and they
just like you know fair abuse away or
somebody just
gets away you get the extra you know
ultra-fire shot to try to
take him out on the way and it's
actually interesting playing against him
now because you now are cognizant of
that so sometimes you're leaving a
little earlier like well i'm gonna get
blasted probably if i just like run away
so
i have to be able to survive that yeah i
think that's one of the decisions all
winston players face it's like okay i've
jumped on this player i've gotten
them weak i can either now get out of my
bubble and try to
finish them off or just kind of hope a
teammate does but now giving him
i think it kind of goes back to more
like that player you know agency that
you were talking about being able to
kind of take over the game
being able to finish it off this nano
boosted rhine
this will never get old you know just to
see in there
and reinhardt nano boosted just swinging
i'm sure it makes the fans out there
happy that i know that was a
a dragon blade elton genji he was able
to take out his uh
it's kind of the bane of existence of a
lot of people
uh but this looks like i guess the
second checkpoint right so
this will unlock the interior of grand
central station
oh this is awesome so it goes in so the
payload kind of goes inside of the
station and uh kind of curves around i
guess
you can see the payload is driven by an
omnic
little easter egg to our production
direct production director on the team
our executive producer he got a name
yes choco
he's gonna be a fan favorite oh he's
even got it on the back i realized i
thought it was like
i thought it was like an unofficial name
like oh yeah
he's got the suit our executive producer
said he's
he's helped us out a lot and it was only
fitting
uh he has a that we he's lived in new
york as well yeah
he helped out a lot on this map and we
have um countless debates about the
right type of pizza
with him as well yes right yeah i mean
the
new york style pizza is the dominant
uh i believe it's the water but uh that
is probably for a different stream
yeah you really want to get into this my
my thoughts on the the water in new york
creating the better pizza dough uh i you
you also notice
uh alice i noticed the new sounds
especially when like ash
shoots uh that is something that uh no
it was discussed at blizzcon line
but i think it's different to kind of
see it in action and also to see
all of the other players at the same
time with those audio changes
it just makes the game feel even more
realistic
yeah the sounds can get really punchy
and it just
feels good to hold the trigger down with
these different heroes
but you also get more information from
it so
we've spent a lot of time not just um
developing what these sounds are but
how they play in different environments
so we've kind of upgraded the entire
sound system across the game so
let's say when um that ash is in a side
room
firing from that room you really kind of
understand where they're at and what
type of environment that they're in
better than you did before and then you
can kind of take that information and
make different decisions
or or additional decisions because of it
all right so we got a map complete from
the offense here
not bad not bad in their first go the
the players are so competitive i have to
say this to the stream that
you're like yeah this is fun like
everybody have a great time and then
everyone's like put your sr in the chat
we're gonna make balanced teams
like who's playing what it's uh it's
just i feel like it's just the nature of
overwatch right like
it it always starts off yeah let's play
for fun and then you know you
you lose a game you're like all right
like everybody pick it up like let's
let's change things it's like that meme
when you like
you're playing relaxing your chair and
then you lose and you lean forward get a
little more
yeah it's those nights of ranked where
you lose
like two and you're like you win one and
then you're like all right play to lose
and then you
you lose a few more and then the next
thing you know you wake up you're like
why'd i do that like 500 sr down the
drain
that's uh so this will be an opportunity
to see like roadhog has a
a solo tank uh coming in for the
offensive side here
uh i feel like he's just gonna be even
on uh
live right he just takes up so much
space jeff
and he takes up space not with a shield
but like just his body
as i say that we we have a zarya swah
but
uh talk to me a little bit about like
the thoughts on you know how how like
the road hogs of the world divas uh even
zarya i know there's some interesting
stuff with zarya
as a solo tank yeah so like i said
before a lot of this is the work of
progress we're still
um yeah sort of addressing here by hero
um but like because
once we started going to one tank it was
sort of the big question was like
kind of hot what direction are we
pushing tanks now we going
we're trying to make roadhog you know a
lot more static
defensively and have you know big
barriers or something to protect his
team
or do we want more the opposite we like
to take the reinhardts and the wrists
and signals and actually
get give them some more aggression and
be a little more like uh
robot diva so we definitely opted for
that ladder rat after playing because
it's like
not only is it just more fun to have
that kind of extra speed and aggression
but you know a lot of what people uh
had a lot of comments on in the past
when the metas get too full of barriers
and shields and honestly even sometimes
when there's just
you know the one erisa blocking you with
just
the chain shields and it's just like you
know people had comments like i feel
like i'm shooting shields all the time
which so like we were definitely hearing
all that and you could see some of the
balance changes we've made
in the past live game i've been trying
to address this but um once we
got into this situation we're like oh
this is sort of an opportunity actually
here
to reduce a lot of these effects and you
know we still want them to be there and
present and be important you can still
block huge abilities
um they still have a decent amount of
health but you know less than they have
before
um but then in response to that we get
to you can see reiner here
you get well he can hit the ball right
there you can cancel it you can cancel
your charge
and you can get two two fire strikes um
so he's the canceling charge is one of
those like sneaky things that seems like
some people might be kind of a minor
change but it almost like completely
changes how he plays a lot of ways it's
actually really fun because you can
uh it has a really fast recovery when
you cancel so you can like charge up to
a group and then cancel and immediately
ult and just like knock everyone down
so the fact that you can even do that is
its own now like
sort of mini game that people play where
you can kind of bluff with it if people
know you have your old if you think you
have your old
you can just charge right at them and
they're trying not to get stunned like
they don't want to fight you necessarily
normally because they don't want to get
or shattered so sometimes you can like
bluff people and are running for cover
and you didn't even have it or you save
it or something so
and it also just allows him to you know
get in there and be more aggressive
without
sacrificing his health part yeah it just
sounds like another uh
change almost like how you kind of
mention like stuff like that winston
combo kind of you know as you're as
you're playing and testing
and seeing all these different things
like yeah where the winston combo you
can you know load up that
secondary fire come to like get the jump
damage land on somebody
take them out like that you kind of have
like this like little metagame with like
reinhardt play right where you know that
you kind of have like this another layer
of cancelling the charge you know being
able to
i remember there was one clip i think
from uh blizzcon line and just like a
trailer where he
he charges towards the team cancels and
then shatters them all
uh being able to make plays like that
just seems
so sick he's also got the ability to um
to control his charge more so you can
actually
turn around corners more oh yeah um so
the the charge while you cancel it's
also more aggressive and it's more
versatile
um i think something else that's really
interesting um
if you look at the if people have
noticed what's happening with zarya
is she has two charges to her bubble now
but the share charges is the trick it's
actually what we play tested in uh
for the fool's patch so as people
probably noted like
you know some of those changes were a
lot of them were just silly kind of fun
like permanently flying sigma
but you know there were some changes he
threw in there i was like let's see how
people react to this i'm curious what
people think like maybe there's
something we can try
and zarya bubbles is one of those things
so
uh aaron you know it's something we just
responded right
oh yeah it took me a while to get used
to the new changes but once
once i really dug in and settled with
these changes i realized it's how i
i always wanted to play reinhardt this
way basically
yeah you know charge it and
then we were joking about that the other
day where uh uh even uh
i'm like yeah like the the canceling the
charge just feels so right that
yeah but you're so like trained to kind
of how it is like where you're just
charging into walls
right that i was like wait i was like i
don't have to do this anymore no like i
can just i can just go
like uh it's it's such like a great
quality of life change
yeah yeah sometimes i think that's
really interesting here is this like
this fight's been going on for a while
neither tank has fallen um and the
support had been doing such a good job
at keeping the tanks up because there's
there's only one of them
that that they have to actually focus on
um and
the fights feel really really good
being the tank player now like the
amount of times you get into this
situation
where it feels hopeless you're low on
health
um there's a bunch of the enemy players
focusing on you
and you're able to still come out of it
um it feels so incredibly good you feel
really powerful
yeah it's uh it i think that that has to
be something that you guys have kind of
gotten in feedback that from a support
point of view you're able to dump
resources
into just one tank and that also
probably frees you up
to do a little bit of other stuff right
where
the batiste can do a little bit more
damage you know zen you can kind of orb
the tank and then focus on the damage
that
uh probably has to be way easier on
supports now
for sure yeah we we got a lot of
feedback from support players
it it's a lot easier to focus and a lot
of times you almost have this like
uh communication between the two support
players and you know you have like
mercy's like i'm just gonna be you know
on tank duty and just be on tank
basically the whole time
and you have like a lucio or something
like that to spot heal everybody else
and
speed everybody up but there's other
strats sometimes we've seen people go
too big
you know main healers essentially and
try to just focus so hard on their tank
that even with like disorder bottom
which is hard to kill them
um so that's going to be just in strat
too so i don't even sure like what their
quote-unquote meta is entirely yet
especially because we're changing things
all the time because it's pretty hard
for them to settle but yeah
uh it's a lot of fun uh this zen
ui is uh new oh yeah uh it actually
looks really
cool uh is this is something obviously
that's uh
incredibly new i think on live like the
it's kind of displayed on the right
yeah we're just looking through this go
ahead sorry jeff i was saying we're
generally looking at
anywhere we can improve uh hero specific
ui stuff like this
and we felt like this could use you know
a big update and be a lot more readable
yeah i think one of the things i'm most
excited about with the healer ui
is um it's not just on zen but it's on
mercy also
you see the portrait of the of the
player that you're healing
um and so it's just a lot easier to kind
of figure out who you've got
um instead of just using something like
a name plate you know
i mean yeah and it's not off to the side
right it's like center screen so you're
able to still kind of focus down the
middle
yeah and you could see his discord is
down there as well so you have like
harmony and discord orbs are kind of
both
shown on each side of the of the alt at
the bottom of the screen
we have an overtime here i i can imagine
the calms are uh
everybody's starting to get pretty
sweaty now
we get towards the end of the map uh
so this has really been i gotta say for
you guys probably uh
this is probably awesome to see like the
game actually being it's one thing i
think to play but now to like observe
and be able to watch
and obviously you know the people you
guys work with every day this has to be
pretty awesome
yeah it definitely is we've been playing
it in this state for a long time too and
it's always
it's always so tough to um to
play a game a certain way at work and
then go home and it
it operates in a totally different way
and you're playing with people online
and you can't help but think like if
only you knew
what i was playing you know every day
um and so it's just it feels really good
to
to have that out in front of in front of
our community so they can kind of see
what we've been doing